if you have seen this question before
then i challenge you to come up with a
different way to solve the question
or if this is the first time you've laid
your eyes on this then well
draw yourself a diagram buckle up and
give it a shot it's 2 14 on my clock at
the moment so i'm gonna give you about
four minutes to have a go at this um
2 15 is just tipped over so
hopefully that'll be enough time to come
up with a result
we want some reasoning and
hopefully more than one way to have a go
at this so enough talking from me um
you'll hear from me again at 2 19 but
feel free to post things in the chat in
the meantime
okay i think i'm going to call it at
that point i could like i said i gave
you this question i chose it because
there are so many different ways to
solve it and so you could spend a long
time on this question is what i'm trying
to say but uh in the interest of
achieving a few other things with
today's lesson i'm going to hit pause on
you there and i'm going to show you a
couple of ways to solve this okay now
really importantly to me is not just
that i show you how to solve this um but
that i try and unpack for you
why it is that i would think that this
would be a logical set of things to do
i've made this analogy in our class many
times before but i often think about
mathematics a bit like cooking
in that sometimes you want to be able to
you know take all these ingredients
together all of the information in a
question and then
you know combine them in such a form
that you end up with something useful at
the end like a result that you were
trying to prove now i am no cook anyone
who has ever tasted anything i have um
any of the output of a kitchen that i've
been a part of um would tell you very
quickly that i am no cook but i can
follow recipes pretty well if you tell
me exactly what to do but as you all
know we don't want you to become coming
back to mathematics we don't want you to
become recipe followers we don't want
you to just take the steps of an
algorithm and reproduce them with no
understanding for one reason because
understanding is the main thing we're
looking for and for another reason which
is that if i show you just the solution
for this but don't unpack for you
how the thinking process underneath why
i came up with a solution you won't be
able to come up with the solution when
you get a slightly different problem and
that's key right so here are um a couple
of ways to solve this and i'm going to
show you first the first solution that
came to mind it is definitely not the
most efficient solution so when some of
you are looking at it you're like sir my
solution light takes half the time okay
um relax i'm getting there i will show
you a better one but this is a very
natural solution to arrive at it's very
um i think it's very sensible and easy
to follow why i got it so
here's the diagram and the result that
we're trying to prove and the question i
actually should scroll back up the
question gives us one other piece of
crucial information or
a guidance actually it says by using
vectors
or otherwise you didn't have to use
vectors but the fact that they've said
by using vectors is kind of making me
think well maybe vectors is the most
straightforward and simplest way to do
this so how can i unpack a solution or a
proof for this using vector logic okay
the first thing is to say that even
though complex numbers and vectors are
closely aligned
ideas they are not the same thing so as
presented to you this result um is not
written in the form of vectors right so
how do i get it in the form of vectors
well i would say you know c
is is shorthand for going from the
origin to that point that's represented
by c so that's a way of writing in
vector notation what c is uh one plus i
i'll come back to this a little bit
later but then you've got an o d here so
get from the origin to d and then you're
going to have o a on the end here okay
so this is the result that i'm trying to
prove but i've just converted it into
vector
notation
so how do i go about setting
out this proof i want to remind you of
when we did trigonometric identity
proofs in extension one it was fairly
standard kind of procedure that if you
get presented with a trigonometric
identity proof um often one of the sides
is very messy and the other side is very
simplified and so we would say well
we're pretty good at simplifying messy
things at least that's what we've spent
a lot of time practicing and so it makes
sense to start from the messy side and
do whatever you can to get yourself over
to the simplified side because our
brains just more naturally fit that way
now i think when you have a look at this
line applying similar sorts of
problem-solving logic it is fairly
obvious that the right-hand side here is
much more messy so i'm going to start
with oh sorry not left-hand side the
right-hand side
i know what my left and my right are um
that right hand side equation there i'm
going to take that and i'm going to see
what i can do with it which will help me
um to try and simplify down what's going
on here okay
now from here i'm going to make things
worse before i make them better when i
notice that i've got this um od vector
and this oa vector
i want to be able to like hopefully a
whole bunch of things should cancel out
to get me to oc that's my destination
right so in order to help me cancel
things out what i notice is that you can
write a vector like od
in terms of a vector like o a there's an
o a hidden inside o d
what i mean by that is od looks like
this yeah from i should have shown it
the other way but um from the origin to
d so how do i connect o a to that well
you could say if i have o a like so
to to write that od in terms of o a you
could say it's o a plus a d do you see
that i'm just stringing together i'm
just concatenating those vectors one at
a time so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to replace this od vector
let's just highlight it here so you can
see what's going on in a second i'm
going to replace that od vector with a
vector that includes o a within it
because then my hope is that things will
start to cancel i can collect like terms
as it were so here comes the new way to
write od i'm going to write it as oa
plus a d and hopefully it's uh
reasonably clear to you um why that is
uh that you know you're going from o to
a and then a to d in sequence so it's
the same as going from o to d directly
probably should mark that into 0. all
right now hopefully you're seeing where
this is going right why this is helpful
to me if you look closely i'm going to
have this
i times oa it's about to cancel with
this minus i times oa so you can see
this is going to be promising for me
right let's go ahead and expand and see
what we get so i'm going to have
multiplied through by 1 first so that's
o a plus od ad rather
then here comes that i o a that i just
mentioned and an i a d we'll have to
work out what to do with that and then
here comes minus i
o a like we saw earlier okay
so um as highlighted you can see here's
the minus
ioa and the plus ioa so those are going
to go they're going to cancel with each
other and that leaves me with these
three other vectors yeah o a
a d
and then i
a d all right